Hello Freak bitches.
Did you see the Philadelphia
conference that I,
that I sent you,
which is about,
uh,
about what people's guilt.
I'm guilty.
What did they do?
There was a,
I was white.
There was a white privilege conference.
I love that article
because weighted this side,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you did.
I was like,
why is my Twitter blowing up?
Oh,
Joe retweeted me.
Uh,
so there was this white
privilege conference,
which was a kind of
politically correct talk fest,
right?
Eh,
and it basically ended up consuming itself
entirely because the people who were
attending it decided that the
conference itself had become too white.
So they went,
they will get it.
They were all there.
So they had this Hashtag um,
white privilege conference.
So what WPC,
so white,
uh,
and it started after one of the speakers
there who was a white historian,
uh,
went over time and won an Asian American,
attend a,
a woman tweeted out,
great keynote,
but going over time a lot.
It is another example of white supremacy,
Hashtag white privileged
conference so wise.
And he also made them
stake of using the n word in his speech.
I mean he obviously was using it in a
historical context cause he was talking
about race in America.
But once that happened,
uh,
I mean what could possibly go wrong using
the n word at a conference about white
guilt,
right?
Then everyone starts tweeting inward.
Never acceptable from Hashtag white folks
lips deeply offensive and traumatizing
hashtag white privilege conference.
So white and that was from a white
tweeter.
So then it's like a snake
eating its fucking tail.
Right?
All these white people just accusing
one another of being too white.
You're all white.
We get it,
we get it.
It's would Michael Shermer
calls virtue signaling.
Right,
right.
It's there.
They're letting the good,
it's perfect for a term there.
They're trying to find someone who's
made some sort of an error and they're
attacking them with full force.
Yup.
And it's also like they're
ignoring context on purpose.
It's like by saying that the word is,
it's never acceptable to say the n word.
By saying that and
putting that in a tweet,
that's not true.
It's just not true.
Like,
if there's a reason to say it,
if you were explaining
something that happened,
what someone said,
how they said it,
you are allowed to repeat the word.
The idea that you're not allowed to
repeat the word around grown adults is to
pretend that word is magic.
Yeah.
So pretend that word's
going to conjure demon.
Well,
it also empowers the word I.
In fact,
I feel stupid for even
having used the phrase,
the end would cause
ordinarily I just say nigger,
if I'm talking about the existence
of that was shot the podcast on,
Hey,
I'm Australian so I
don't understand context.
Right.
But I mean I was talking about this a,
I'm on my podcast about,
I do think that we,
we've gotten away from like where is the
other person's heart and what is their
intention?
Yeah,
there's,
there is,
um,
let's see,
you could think of it like an
Amoeba around your physical body,
cloud
of,
um,
pulsating thought forms.
And,
uh,
as you're imagining,
you know,
a,
the beautiful elements of life and things,
it's,
it seems to be in a kind of order and uh,
and maybe kind of wafting upward it,
these are like,
uh,
the,
the spiritual positive,
uh,
kind of frameworks sometimes that
you're seeing life through when you're
tripping,
you know,
and seeing the connections between things,
lines forming and things like that.
The,
the more kind of organic
geometries that that show up,
you see this intelligence of life and the,
uh,
the,
the light of divine intelligence
that came through for Allison,
like in this language,
it,
it's seems to be weaving things together
and when you're in touch with that
infinite light that
seems to be the source,
uh,
then that is it.
You can keep it upwardly moving and
very evolutionarily caught cosmically
consciously moving forward.
And when then you're thinking regretful
thoughts or thinking negative thoughts
and anger and things like that.
There's a constriction that
goes on in your heart I think,
and kind of shuts things down in
that kind of like you were saying,
twisting in,
curling in and darkening and,
and things are,
are all,
uh,
things that when you're journeying,
you see them manifest literally
and you're the flow of your,
the theater of your imagination.
And so I think you really
beautifully described that.
Uh,
just in that I was totally there.
I think it's a disease of consciousness.
I think it's very similar
to catching a cold that,
you know,
uh,
you don't see the cold,
you don't see a disease,
you don't see it,
but it affects you.
And I think there's an analogy to be
made about diseases of consciousness that
you can get locked into these
terrible ways of looking at the world.
I found for a while I enjoyed living
within very strict guidelines.
It was just easier when we go to a
restaurant because I used to joke that I
would like to be buried and a bread
basket with a fuck ton of butter,
like bread and butter is my thing.
Um,
and when we go to a restaurant
and they bring the bread,
like I just,
I don't even touch it.
It's not mine.
I just,
it was so,
it was nice to not even have to
think about all these things.
Um,
but then,
I don't know,
I,
a few months ago I just thought,
I don't feel like this is really
doing anything for me anymore.
And I miss my lean cuisine dinners,
which is what I used to eat.
[inaudible] cuisine.
They're not bad.
Yes,
I know all the things you can miss.
I know.
Well,
healthy choice dinners as well.
What the fuck you doing with that process?
Bullshit.
I know I had stopped eating
the process of which I missed.
I missed the bullshit I missed.
I missed the wood pulp wood.
What is Wood Paul?
It's probably some kind
of filler in there.
I'm just saying there's like wood
pulp in your food in Parmesan cheese,
I think.
Why didn't that come out recently?
What?
Right?
Yeah.
Jamie knows Jamie,
what are you talking about?
What?
What kind of Parmesan cheese and just the,
the,
you know the bottle of
Kraft parmesan cheese.
It came out that a certain percentage of
it is like wood shavings or something.
Hearts.
Jesus Christ.
Why are they putting wood in
your cheese so that there's a,
it's day just plants though.
That's right.
Cheese.
You sprinkle co what?
Cellulose.
Okay.
Hotly contested.
But perhaps now for reasons,
right?
Think FDA investigation found
that a Pennsylvania company,
castle cheese incorporated had doctored
it's so-called Parmesan with it.
Mix of cheap cheddar cheese and cellulose.
Also known as wood pulp.
Oh,
well if you say cellulose,
that doesn't sound right.
Yeah.
Cellulose just sounds like
like fiber from plants.
Plant material.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well there shouldn't be plant
material and fucking cheese.
You can't,
assholes should go to jail for that.
Putting fucking wooden cheese.
You can't just do that and you can't
mix cheddar cheese with wood and call it
Parmesan.
So attached should have
its own new variety name,
wood,
pulp,
cheesy thing,
right.
Just call it that.
Yeah.
People would buy it.
My mouth is watering.
Well,
you're eating lean cuisine and saying,
I don't know what it is in the
processed frozen dinners that I like,
but that's what I like.
Sort of like when I smoked,
I was like,
yeah,
I think it's the fiberglass
in the cigarettes that I like.
Yeah.